this is our first viewing of rubber I've
never seen this movie a you
you saw it a while ago but you don't
like when I first came out I don't
remember a whole lot cuz like we were
all kind of talking and drinking it was
kind of like just a Halloween ish kind
of movie night thing there's been a lot
of people that have asked me to do this
like ever since it came out it's so much
so I'm kind of shocked there's not as
well as I thought it would not be at
least like 10 years I think it's only
like 5 or 8 or something like that was
just still you know a little bit ago I'm
assuming it's a bit of a comedy I would
I don't know if it's better if it is or
isn't but but so many people that I
asked him this is a whole like weird
sub-genre of these I feel because
there's Hillard Blanc yeah and there's a
yeah there's killer tomatoes obviously
this is a killer tire I want to say
there was a killer turkey one at some
point oh there's like three or four
years like killing thanks killing
anything can kill you it turns out yeah
it's kinda like that thing anything can
give you cancer movies can kill you this
is my first viewing he's kind of first
viewing because he don't remember that
well reviewing yeah this is our first
viewing of Aruba man we put the Swedish
artistic foreign film or something well
I can safely say I have questions figure
this one out in the Steven Spielberg
movie et why is the alien Brown no
reason in Oliver Stone's JFK Weiss the
president suddenly assassinated by some
stranger no reason why was Transformers
vibe even made no reason why don't we
ever see the characters go to the
bathroom he's gonna take a shit on
camera I hope the whole film is 2 hours
of this you've been I see jack plotnick
I am absolutely convinced that plotnick
is not a real name I'm totally convinced
David Lynch and Charlie Kaufman did this
film and they didn't want anyone to know
they did all look like fake names that's
it you go to
your name right after the thais hole
here's the title but more importantly my
name dude when did the wheels and the
bus stop going round and round I live
again roll the credits it's like we got
a Mexican standoff I feel like this is
all something that would definitely
happen in California pay money to watch
a time it does seem very California it's
about the experienced band they'll
change the life it's a metaphor for how
modern transportation is ruined America
really really why is that pushing the
limit for me that the tire has to drink
I don't know why that's just like bail
that's stupid Hey joke actually it works
this time you're driving you gave more
motivation to the tire you talked to the
tire for hours
how are feces like a tire burning dump
like a holocaust probably runs into
Norman
I just reenact full psycho checking it
he's just talking with the tire tires
taking the shower and then yeah oh hey I
was just kidding is that really what
we're doing here yes you just know this
is somebody's fetish yeah you look like
you just got your hair wet
yeah really that's what okay that's my
biggest blob all of us very well master
yes I am the fuck kill a turkey movies
you're talking about it is like this
movie is listening to our jokes and
saying oh yeah well we can take it a
step further weirdos
oh you are asking for an invitation to
the race no Michael Keaton was in this
you got nothing better to do over here
start talking rubbish rubber not rubbish
yeah I love things oh I was just kidding
man every
I'm a yes I think it was something in
that turkey I think you're right yes I
remember I have the lasagna I can say
I'm annoyingly intrigued it's like
getting stuck next to a weird person out
of plane you can't go anywhere so you
might as well just listen to what they
have to say keep men here someone a
plane just start talking about this idea
and these people are watching through
the binoculars and this tower goes
around killing people and they're
talking about while watching the movie
now get that dirty tire out of the pool
or I'm gonna get really mad hey no need
to use slurs it is not a dirty tires now
scram you are getting on my nerves don't
I'm gonna tell my father wait what's
your connection can I ask you some
questions for the investigation sure go
ahead
what is up with your outfit it's been
six hours the poison has had time to
take effect we can stop I can say even
for a movie about a killer tire this is
not what I was expecting
listen I have something important to
announce we're not gonna make our money
back on this picture now pointing at me
and shoot no way Doug you do it
yeah Doug gladly Oh God the kid was
right the killer is a tire doesn't mean
man tire watching exercise videos watch
when they get out pools going in the
pool blowing shit up tire squash the
spider it wasn't cool I just feel like
my life is going in circles
I'll give you an hour to find them you
might have been out there Jason you feel
like the writer of this was just like
I've been assigned to write a tire movie
it just has to have a killer tire okay
I'll give you a goddamn killer tire
movie-going all Aronofsky on this shit
what's the problem they just stop and
look at them
Gaza's final performance once soil Oh
does this movie is literally a tire fire
is it actually gonna do like every joke
we've made this is so probably he who
saves one tire saves the tire and tires
oh my god I'm watching racing to him
that's like the Olympics so watching TV
what should we do well call the cable
company get them to offer 500 channels
they'll keep him busy for I have been a
very naughty girl I almost feel like
these people are mocking the guy who
wrote and directed human centipede like
no this is really what was going on yeah
the scene makes no sense at all and not
that it was great to begin with but at
least I understood it stop doing our job
we'll try to speed things up now hmm you
can go back to your place if you have
this had a big budget Christoph Waltz
would play him and by he's been
reincarnated as a tricycle I'm not a
character I'm just watching it's good
give it the wheels on the wheelchair
together now you're just trying too hard
we got a whole new round of jokes to use
them we're gonna have to cycle through
them all I'm gonna go if I had a jigsaw
puppet in the Saw movies this whole
movie is kinda like a Zen riddle uh more
it makes sense the more questions I have
don't you see it's more powerful now
because there's three of them there's
three wheels oh shit he's subbing in the
army of the undead rubber again we're
just making jokes stop making our jokes
go your day of the treasure
hey I was the tire
I got admit I didn't really give in my
own special thanks to everyone who
actually stayed with the snow you go
first
[Laughter]
that was something that happened I think
yeah it was so pointless it's like I'm
almost yeah yeah it's so direct and how
pointless it is and how much of its time
its gonna waste I mean it's one of those
things where it's like okay so really
nothing did go anywhere a part of me is
almost annoyed they didn't kind of
explain more like with the cry no that's
like they're watching the movie instead
of why did they kill them off and then
but again that's also part of the fun is
that you're just never gonna get an
answer out of it
so it does kind of feel like a troll
movie but like it in a good way like
it's definitely self-aware like I know
yeah yeah there it is yeah I can't be
angry I can't be joyous I can't really
be but because it was so pointless so I
guess it really does achieve kind of
what it said the very opening it was
going to do it was as advertised
yeah a pointless story about a killer
tire yeah no nope oh he's just like the
Kennedy assassination the Holocaust and
what was the other example UT is brown
and ye T is brown no reason no no reason
um no ending
you